cette photo est incroyable c'est ce que
je préfère dans le fait de prendre des
photos tu te promènes et tu trouves des
endroits comme celui ci ça me rend un
peu euphoriques c'est l'effet que font
tes yeux en ce moment
c'était grave nécessité ouais un peu
peut-être qu'on se recroisera ici un
jour
tadic ils étaient mignons les mbochis
c'est mignon ce mec là
prétendre me lunettes de soleil tu as
je crois que tu pourrais vendre cette
photo mais je trouve qu'il manque un
truc est sûre toutes tes photos toi
[Musique]
je t'aime test
bon retour dans le monde des vivres
je crois qu'il
aimerait seulement de voir une dernière
fois juste une minute tard
puis les mains et
non
[Musique]
je comprends pas qu'est ce qui se passe
quand la séparation est traumatisante
liens souvent quelque chose en suspens
il est dans l'antre 2 ils essaient de
venir à toi
ouvre la borie dans l'assistance
chasseuse de fantômes est arrivé un oui
jacques et sérieuse
tu sais à bouger désolé non c'était moi
si tu parviens à franchir la barrière tu
pourrait ne jamais revenir
[Musique]
je vais le trouver
[Applaudissements]
je suis toujours la thèse
[Musique]